beyonce's new song is breaking the
internet my manager called and said that
beyonce wanted you one of your songs i'm
like holy crap what is going on another
one
and brittany is getting ready to tell
everybody the t in her autobiography
plus kim k on her kids meeting pete and
why she won't be walking down the aisle
anytime soon i think i'm definitely
going to be really cautious because i
you know have proven that maybe i'm not
the best at it
and could the god of thunder be ready to
hang up his hammer now is it safe to
assume that this will be your final
go-around as thor i look it yeah maybe i
don't know et's the download starts
right now
all right y'all it is time to put your
dancing shoes on we begin with beyonce
shaking up the world with her new summer
anthem break my soul
[Music]
oh it's already on heavy rotation don't
you worry about that but in true beyonce
fashion she surprised the beehive
releasing the song last night hours
earlier than we expected queen b's
bringing back 90s house music with this
track which features new orleans bounce
music legend big frida e.t spoke with
her about the life-changing moment and
working with beyonce for a second time
but this time in the studio
i needed an asthma pump once i left out
of the building my manager you know
called and said that beyonce want to use
one of your songs
on her new album i'm like holy crap what
is going on another one last night i
mean when i heard it i just was like in
tears you know grateful
you know
still trying to pinch myself to wake up
frida first appeared on b's 2016 hit
song formation off her lemonade album
i came to slay [ __ ]
now we're kidding huge reaction to
beyonce's new song her desi's child
bandmate kelly rowland celebrated this
morning dancing with her one-year-old
son
bee's mom posted our interview with her
saying break my soul is my summer anthem
right now this song makes me dance like
it's no tomorrow
i just posted recently that i really
miss her singing and i do
cynthia arrivo shared this video of her
dance session last night and titus
burgess well he was in tears
and you won't break my song
[Music]
he also posted this video of his
sleepless night saying never has the
repeat button ever gotten more love and
use and you know titus of course is an
official member of the beehive remember
remember he once recreated one of her
music
videos something don't taste right cause
it ain't right like when you take a sip
of water and it turns out to be sprite i
know your secret and now i regret ever
have you danny i uh i saw your reaction
i did
by the way i was supposed to be at a
dinner 20 minutes from there was very
late but you know what people understand
okay it's beyonce all right everybody by
the way twitter is so undefeated y'all
some are calling bee's new track an ode
to workplace liberation and say it's
time to say bye bye to the nine to five
one twitter user asking is she telling
us to quit our jobs because i will
beyonce i will another tweeting beyonce
said the great resignation starts today
release your job
break my soul is the first single off
beyonce's upcoming album renaissance
which drops july 29th is she going to be
picking up people's bills when they quit
their jobs uh we'll find out she's
better just kidding i'm coming back
because while beyonce is bearing her
soul britney spears is ready to share
her story in a new tell-all a source
tells e.t britt is working on a book
about everything she went through our
source says the book is going deep she
is sharing all details and not holding
anything back now forbes has reported
that the book deal is worth 15 million
dollars
[Music]
but they can never take away your truth
meanwhile et's source also says britney
and new husband sam eskari are not going
on a honeymoon just yet saying they are
just enjoying this moment together now
it's been nearly two weeks since
brittany and sam's star-studded wedding
but if you're wondering what madonna
gave her as a gift well it was jewelry
our store says brittany was so thrilled
to have her there to celebrate along
with her other friends moving on kim
kardashian is also dishing on love and
lessons learned in a revealing interview
with today we know kim and boyfriend
pete davidson are closer than ever but
are wedding bells in her future
i think i'm definitely going to be
really cautious because i you know have
proven that maybe i'm not the best at it
and i don't want to make that mistake
again
kim also cautions when it comes to
family saying she waited six months to
introduce her four kids to pete
i have a sister that has been through it
all and we talked about it and i
consulted with a few therapists and
friends that have been through it and i
think it's different for everyone and
different things work for different
people but you just have to do what
feels right
the reality star getting candid about
co-parenting and coming together with ex
kanye west the kids you know spent the
day with him and then we had a big
father's day dinner of course i wanted
to honor and respect the amazing people
and fathers men in my life that have
raised me and are raising my children so
every everything's going good
as for her infamous met gala moment and
the internet drama that followed kim
says she only wore the dress for four
minutes after losing 16 pounds to fit
into the iconic gown i looked at it like
a roll and i really wanted to wear this
dress like i it was really important to
me and
you know it actually taught me a lot
about my lifestyle and my health and
since then afterwards i continued to eat
really healthy i mean i'm down 21 pounds
now and i just completely changed my
lifestyle
it looks like kim might be playing
matchmaker for her sister just days
after chloe shut down rumors she was
dating another nba player source tells
et she's dating a private equity
investor she met through kim and things
are going well
more evidence the good american mogul is
moving on she shared this instagram
story about healing
also bouncing back after breakups the
exes of kardashian x's julia fox and
emilia gray hamlin shared more than just
their kardashian connection over the
weekend the former flames of kanye west
and scott disick both donning bleach
blonde eyebrows and touched tongues in a
new instagram pic shared by emilia of
what appeared to be a pretty wild night
out the model has a lot to celebrate she
just marked her milestone 21st birthday
last week all right guys graham norton
is a late night staple in the uk but is
he eyeing james corden's late late show
gig in america e.t was with the graham
norton show host in london to celebrate
paramount plus coming to the uk but he
admitted he's not exactly looking to
fill court in seat when he leaves the
late late show next spring i mean i love
going to america but working there
particularly a job like that you know
that is that's a job you know i don't do
a job i have a lovely time i do a once a
week show where is that that's like
joining the priesthood to do that show
five nights a week that's proper graft
and i don't know how he's done it for as
long as he has well done to him well on
to a couple who's also working hard tim
mcgraw and faith hill yeah they starred
together in paramount plus yellowstone
spin-off 1883 and et's cassie dolores
caught up with the two about another
major work milestone
[Music]
this year marks 25 years since your
first duet what do you remember about
that song it's your love
well i was so pregnant
faith was craving milkshakes when we
were shooting the video
i craved a lot but milkshake i needed it
and she had a milkshake when we were
when we were shooting the video and and
so she if you look really closely in a
few shots you'll see a milkshake stain
no they took that out
you can still see it you can still see
it tim dapper in a suit and faith
wearing a lace corset under her jacket
hit the blue carpet alongside fellow
paramount plus stars including kevin
costner he's in the middle of shooting
season five of yellowstone how does
shooting this season compare to the four
prior it it's really good to be out
there i mean honestly it's it's hard to
get tired of those mountains and rivers
and horses and things like that
[Music]
this upcoming season which premieres
november 13th is super-sized there's 14
episodes instead of 10. if it doesn't
surprise you it's very unlikely that it
will surprise an audience helen mirren
and harrison ford join taylor sheridan's
yellowstone universe they'll play
another generation of duttons in the
prequel 1923. are you in touch with
harrison and helen about the universe no
no
no
i'm not in the advice business
was your beautiful wife here tonight
she's not she's not you know we have
four kids she's missing kevin costner
tonight she is missing kevin costa she's
such a huge fan of yellowstone so um so
yeah she'll be freaking out over the
fact that she's not here
david o yellow stars in the spinoff 1883
the bass reef story about the legend of
the lone ranger while sylvester stallone
plays a gangster in tulsa king and he's
loving the fashion i go from the shoes
up i'm not messing around
because i think a lot of these for some
reason
the gangsters may not have been the most
erudite educated human beings but they
dressed well
and i guess they knew they weren't going
to be real wrong
what do we have to do to get a reality
show from you yeah why don't you bring
that up i'm doing one i thought you know
i live a real a life a weird life funny
like because of daughters so it's going
to go down
august
all right speaking of reality what's
better than one former housewife
returning to tv try having eight come
back yeah and bringing a ton of drama on
the real housewives ultimate girls trip
ex-wives club with the og of orange
county
vicky gunvalson leading the pack
and she's got a new man named michael
after ending her two-year engagement to
politician steve lodge
there isn't very many people that don't
want to be in a relationship that i know
all my family's married are in a
relationship all my friends are married
in relation it's a couple's world out
there she'll need all the love she can
get to help deal with another og new
york's dorinda medley she hosts all the
ladies at her estate bluestone manor and
the claws immediately come out birds of
a feather flock together i am not
flocking with that bird i think she's
mean
we filmed with her for a week and it was
awful she made everybody in the place
cry but i think eva phaedra cried i mean
everybody cried and their fear gets even
nastier off camera vicki's giving e.t
the detail on their text fight vicky
says leave me out of your
press you have zero knowledge of who i
am okay
i own four houses my own business for 32
years and no one gifted me anything
go away
go away
the cast also includes taylor armstrong
brandy glanville jill zaran eva marcel
and phaedra parks when it premieres june
23rd on peacock now on to more drama
only this time in the middle of the
woods running wild with bear grylls is
back with a slew of a-listers including
natalie portman simul liu ashton kutcher
florence pew and anthony anderson yeah
here's a preview
this season we're taking that upper
level i'm teaching my celebrity guests
survival skills
your life will depend on it then they
need to face the wild alone
and failure is not an option i'm sure if
he's asking me to do it i can't do it
right all of a sudden he's gone he
doesn't even cook your breakfast or
anything everything's lethal out here
there's no turning back oh god
oh who talked me into this
check it out july 25th on national
geographic well listen a group who could
have benefited from some bear grylls
survival skills the cast of yellow
jackets if cassie caught up with the
stars melanie linski and tony cypress
and tried to her best to get some season
two scoop he said when did you start
shooting the next season
yes mid-august yeah
yeah i know excited going back to
vancouver i love working with melanie i
think we work really well together so
it'll be really fun to do more scenes
together hopefully have those intimate
moments where we get to
break down our walls you guys are like
we're not telling anything that was a
great one
that was good though
and the giant squid i'm really looking
forward to the giant squid i mean
[Laughter]
while we're talking edge of our seats tv
we've got to talk stranger things one of
your favorites our favorites really
netflix says the super size final
episode will have a run time of get this
two hours and 20 minutes volume 2 drops
july 1st and by the look of the just
released trailer it is going to be one
intense ending
it might not work out for us this time
it is over
now i just want you to
watch by now you recognize the music in
the trailer as kate bush's running up
the hill but because of the show kate's
song hit number one on the singles chart
and she put out a statement on her
website saying i salute the duffer
brothers for their courage i want to
thank them so much for bringing the song
into so many people's lives i'm
overwhelmed by the scale of affection
and support the song is receiving i have
to admit i feel really moved by it all
thank you so much for making the song a
number one in such an unexpected way now
this makes kate the oldest woman to top
the singles chart on cd cher who
congratulated her via tweet saying we
had to fight our way through the
testosterone curtain and we did it so
the girls who came after us could sing
as long as they want to with mega
respect
so fans are gonna be feeling the love
with thor when he returns to the big
screen july 8th et's cassie dolores
spoke with the god of thunder himself
about his future with the franchise
and flick
oh you flick too hard damn it now is it
safe to assume that this will be your
final go-around as thor look yeah maybe
i don't know each time i've done it i've
sort of thought okay i don't know what
else i could say is this character and
thanks for having me great and then
something else has come up look i'm open
to anything you know if i'm lucky enough
to do more then great if not it's
fantastic you know i'm thankful either
way
[Music]
the first time chris wielded the hammer
was 11 years ago now he's back for his
ninth movie in the marvel universe for
love and thunder in theaters july 8th
natalie portman returns to the franchise
as his former flame and the new thor
jane
they must defeat a new villain played by
christian bale
so this is my vow
oh god she will die it's just my first
bad guy
[Music]
you never forget your first and i think
it's the most insane thing i've been a
part of uh it's wacky it's wild it's fun
we now have a
beautiful love story the center of it
what's in family three four years eight
years seven months and six days give or
take that girl looks ripped were you two
gym buddies we were a bit yeah yeah she
she worked hard i just want to say that
was very very impressive what you did
back there
[Music]
she lifted a lot more weights on this
one to sort of sculpt her muscles tessa
thompson in the gym with us a lot too we
had a big ice bath there which we'd
rotate through and that was that became
the kind of the most noise was made in
that thing she came in first i ended
three three and a half minutes and so
then we all have to try and do three
minutes do you have a moment that you
remember
the magnitude of what was happening in
your life the first time we went to
comic-con and we showed the trailer i
mean my publisher said do you have any
idea what just happened or what this
means and i sort of understood due to
that you know thousands of people were
screaming and and
had given us the tip of approval sitting
on the stage just then and like
thousands of people like was sort of
mind-blowing eight nine years later on
the avengers infinity war and end game
press tours that was really the
culmination of all of the marvel films
the whole universe coming together and i
think we all realized and recognized at
that point that it's probably never
going to be done again and i have such
beautiful nostalgic memories about that
moment
now you posted that your kids are only
allowed to dress as thor ingest we've
got some serious power in those are they
unfazed by your marvel theme it's just
normal for them you know i mean they
come on set and they get excited for a
couple of minutes and then they realize
it's a pretty boring process
but now i let them wear whatever they
want in fact i think wonder woman is
their favorite character it's definitely
my boy's favorite character what's left
on the bucket list i
just want to be home now with the kids
and and just just hang out and do the
usual sort of school drop off pick up
you know weekends and sports and all
this sort of fun stuff that uh that the
kids are involved in at the moment
someone who can check off become an
internet star off their bucket list
miles telling us still ahead we take a
look back at the actors career and what
is everyone so mad about miles what a
time to be alive
et's the download we'll be right back
[Music]
so
[Music]
one of the summer's biggest movies has
also given us the summer of miles teller
it seems like rooster and his epic
mustache are all over the internet but
as nichelle turner shows us et has had
its eye on miles long before he took
flight in top gun maverick
what a time to be alive
i was in my underwear eating breakfast
at you know 1 p.m today you forget that
that this is the kind of fandom that
attracts
these these people
i'm a great drinking buddy i've gotten
more than one movie just offered like
drinking at a
bar i just want to do the roles that you
know that satisfy me
and if and if that also appeases you
know the audience then then we're
we're in it together
[Music]
yeah at 35 miles is having a moment
maybe it's the stash or that pilot's
swag but his blink and you missed it
shirtless scene and top gun maverick has
the internet captivated how does this
i showed up as
in shape as i could i've never had more
oil
on me
running miles biggest fan club wife
kelly who has no shame posting thirst
traps of her husband which are now
dubbed teller talk
i don't have you know uh instagram or
tick tock or anything but i know my i
know my wife i'll just see her on her
phone and then she'll start cracking up
i've never really experienced something
like this in my life
some top gun secrets miles didn't know
the cameras were rolling when he did the
now iconic shimmy and he really played
the piano in this nod to the original
goodness
gracious it's a pretty tricky song but
luckily i played piano when i was
younger so i just had to dust it off a
little bit
as for the mustache it was mile's idea
tom was on board but kelly was not i
felt different people looked at me
different you know i kind of felt like a
cowboy or something did you oh yeah man
started walking just you know more
confident it was great
tom i don't think even had any idea and
then when we did our first camera test
together he hadn't seen me for a while
and so i had it for then and he was
really excited about her she wanted me
to shave it that's why that's why it's
never made a comeback
go have fun when we first met a 24 year
old miles in 2011 he was in the remake
of footloose and told us this it's my
secret weapon and i actually you know
it's hard to act like you can't dance
when you know that you can
[Music]
after college miles landed his first
major movie role alongside nicole kidman
in the 2010 film rabbit hole he earned
just five thousand dollars when i kind
of was first getting rolls did i think
that you had to look like an abercrombie
and fitch model apparently to get a lead
yeah i did think that and i knew that
wasn't my you know that wasn't my forte
if that's how hollywood worked then then
i would have a difficult time getting
the lead role
these are drummer thumbs by the way
that's what my mom told me that when i
first started drumming she's like oh
yeah those are your grandfather's
drumming thumbs i'm like
no they're not they're just fat thumbs
that i'm using to drunk
miles actually played the drums and
gained critical acclaim in 2014's
oscar-winning film whiplash his paycheck
eight thousand dollars
and did you know miles was actually
supposed to play ryan gosling's role in
la la land but says he was later told he
was no longer creatively right for the
project
this was like the most physical role
that i had done i was actively you know
kind of looking for something that was a
little more you know juiced up a little
more pumped up from the divergent series
to fantastic four miles proved his medal
as an action star in 2016 he dropped 20
pounds and had six percent body fat to
play a boxer in the true story bleed for
this 140 pounds even
it was a long day that last fight scene
was like 16 hours and they brought in
all these pizzas and somebody handed me
a pizza i could have cried yeah like i
woke up the next morning with the pizza
box next to me in bed
sergeant shuman
[Music]
is there something in you that connects
to these type of movies to celebrate our
heroes i grew up in a pretty small town
a lot of my boys are military and yeah i
don't think there's enough of these
films being made and with these two
stories i just really felt for the guys
i was playing some other things you may
not know about miles he actually plays
four instruments total piano drums
guitar and saxophone he once sang and
danced on stage with keith urban
[Music]
and he's very sarcastic my biceps would
be taking up the whole room
there's a lot of hot guys in this movie
i heard miles tellers in this movie
apparently he's really hot i think it's
all downhill from here
still when it comes to the two favorite
ladies in his life his mom and his wife
miles is seriously devoted my mom is a
wonderfully strong powerful intelligent
you know smart beautiful woman and she
ran my household i love making movies
but my you know my personal life and my
time with kelly and you know my family
my friends those those the moments i
really you know i really save her
i've been lucky she's she's always been
my support and my but yeah she's she's
happy when she gets me back for sure did
you bring your wife
did i not mention her and we'll edit
that and i started with my wife of
course i brought my wife she's my
forever plus one baby
oh i like that i love him i'm obsessed
all right guys i'm on the mouth training
for us today yeah that's right tune in
tomorrow for another episode of et's
bye
[Music]